welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of i am
groot all five shorts now streaming on
disney plus each with some really clever
animation details of just some awesome
mcu easter eggs hey this thing's got
marvel studios in front of it so i'm
breaking it down starting with the first
episode gert's first steps all of these
shorts open with the typical marvel
studios fanfare but groot cruelly fast
forwards through it come on girl you
know i always go through this part frame
by frame to see what character moments
marvel studios swapped in and out of the
letters but notice how the remote he
uses if he pauses the right second
actually has different icons on the
buttons than any of our remote controls
which is just interesting because much
of the guardian's consumer tech on board
the milano and the binitar have been
familiar terran gadgets that peter coyle
had with them whether it's walkman or
the defenders game that groot plays in
infinity war just find it interesting
that groot is watching all this on a
kind of extraterrestrial television set
that still uses infrared signals that
you know that you know beam out of your
remote and it all fast forwards the way
vhs does
yes i am overthinking it but that's what
i do but the final marvel studios title
switches over into cross-hatched brush
strokes the way it would in episodes of
what if just seems like something the
mcu will do for animated titles we open
on groot shortly after the events of the
first guardians of the galaxy in 2014
this was after rocket replanted one of
groot's broken twigs into this pot and
then he re-sprouted to the right is a
stereo probably so that he can continue
to dance whenever drax isn't looking and
to the left is a yarrow root this is a
vegetable that nebula and gamora
bickered over in guardians vol 2. can we
say that yara root no it's not ripe yet
and i hate you
it's not ripe by the look of it here
it's purple sprouts make it look like
it's just a tad overripe and as time
passes the yarrow root rots as groot
gets spritzed by these drones but after
eating too many cheesy puffs he grows
into the volume two baby groot form that
we know and love and after getting moved
out of the way for a new house plant
behind him you can see on the tape deck
with the awesome mix volume 2. we
presume loaded in there because this
would be after volume one peter quill
would have just opened up this new tape
from his mom probably would be playing
it at this point groot jealously rages
against this tree much like he rages
against drax when drax breaks the amps
in the guardians vol 2 opening sequence
groot pulls apart this tree spewing a
green gummy interior but don't worry in
the credits it says no tree creatures or
planets were harmed during the making of
this short actually every short has a
similar joke in the credits just like
this on to the next episode the little
guy now this episode opens with the
milano parked on a dry planet and yes
this would still be the milano because
remember when groot was baby groot that
would be between guardians vol 1 and
volume 2 and the milano was not wrecked
until volume 2. it's between volume 2
and infinity war when they get the
benatar now on the branch is a bailou or
velou remember the value are the furry
bird like creatures from bear hearts in
guardians vol 2. they also show up among
the collector's collections and the
mission breakout ride at the disney
parks groot builds a house of twigs with
a wind chime but it gets overtaken by
the blue leading group 2 scream in my
favorite jump cut of the season
yes i will be using that as meme groot
finds a tiny race of blue grunts gruns
are in marvel comics in the 70s from a
thor comic and from giant-sized
defenders they're these plump yellow
dudes that can convert solar energy from
their antennae to create superhuman
strength in a force field but without
their antennae they are powerless now
groot exposing them to sunlight here
might be what allows their technology to
advance so rapidly if you think about it
and thank god he ended them when he did
because who knows what would happen or
what will happen these grun's motion
asking him for food and he just responds
yeah he loves being the big guy for a
change and i love how this little
parable mirrors the avengers conflicts
of the mcu groot looms down on this
civilization as a conquering giant much
like a celestial or galactus devourer of
worlds and the first thing that happens
is he's attacked by these warriors with
slings and notice how each of these
three is painted with different markings
these might be the early avengers of
this race each branded with a different
costume and sigil but their weapons
rapidly advance from laser pistols to a
mounted gun to a fully avengers assemble
fleet of jetpacks and hovercraft we saw
this kind of micro civilization rapidly
advanced gag and one of my favorite
treehouse of horror episodes of the
simpsons which also came from an episode
of twilight zone these guys frightened
groot into pooping out a leaf that they
use for sustenance and as they gobble it
up i love how you can see this elderly
female grunt crying tears of joy groot
finally understands his purpose and
tries to feed them but
[Music]
yes such is the case for gods of the mcu
from the celestials to the gods of
omnipotent city eventually they're just
gonna screw up and kill assault and move
on yet notice at the end nine pop up
from the ruins and we'll someday avenge
their people i'm sure and in the credits
it reads no tree creatures blue
creatures manta bird creatures or tiny
blue grunge creatures were harmed during
the making of this short by confession
time i want to be like thor he's got the
best stuff the cool armor cool weapons
cool hair i can't just snap my fingers
and get my very own stormbreaker or a
flowing mane but what i can get it's
g-fuel's new lightning lemonade
collector's box inspired by marvel
studios thor love and thunder this
collector's box comes with the hydration
tub and the shaker cup which is great
because then you can feel like thor
anytime you are thirsty also lightning
lemonade perfect summer drink in that it
is everything you love about thor and
lemonade in the same can plus there's no
calories no sugar and no caffeine you
just pour a scoop of the powder in give
yourself one of these
and
wow god of lemonade there's no calories
no sugar no caffeine instead it's loaded
with focus aminos plus a bunch of
antioxidants and vitamins to keep you
hydrated no matter what you're doing
making videos gaming or patiently
waiting for your hair to grow long
enough to reach your shoulders and while
you're doing that you might as well get
your godly hands on the collector's box
right so click the link in the
description and use the code new
rockstars to get 30 off and thanks again
to g fuel for sponsoring this video on
to the next episode groot's pursuit this
episode opens on the eclector this is
the ravager ship captained by yondu yet
to be destroyed after yondu gets revenge
against taserface and the other
mutineers and wrecks that ship as he
leaves with rocket and groot and craglin
and vol 2 on the quadrant i don't think
these shorts are really there yet at
that point in history really it tells us
that groot might have spent some other
time on the collector before going there
in volume 2. groot straps to his head a
wristwatch fitness tracker with alien
writing on it the lettering looks
vaguely scroll-ish but honestly this
might be new groot follows the trail of
fluid into the bathroom where he sits
for a bit on the toilet reading this
book and the cover shows an image of
thanos a bird's tail feather another
villoo and a fuchsia banana and the
title is written in cree you can
actually translate this using the
translator from taylor tovan's
collection in the mission breakout ride
line and it translates to dumps happen
presumably a cree version of everybody
poops it's just pretty hilarious that
the cree wanted to include thanos in the
idea of everyone pooping now when the
fitness tracker dies out groot smacks it
and it talks to him
you have walked 300 steps
yes this device's voice is actually a
vocal cameo by guardians director james
gunn now the specimen he pursues is
called an iwua it mimics his form and
groot challenges him to a dance-off
which is essentially how the guardians
save the universe in their most recent
conflict the dance battle to save the
universe and that's how groot ends up
tricking this guy into the airlock dance
battles they work every time ooh that
talks to him oh no no no my friend try
again it's not step step
yes this voice actor is trevor duvall
who voices rocket raccoon in the
guardians of the galaxy animated series
on disney xd now the credits of this
episode say no tree creatures or liquid
creatures were harmed in the making of
this short next episode groot takes a
bath this short and sweet episode opens
with the milano parked on this planet
with some interesting flora groot turns
a mud puddle into a hot spring mud bath
species-wise he is considered a flora
colosse so yeah his tree-like anatomy
does sprout super fast but just
interesting to note that soon after he
trims his hedges his green leaves all
turn to brown and fall like while this
mud may give him a short-term plumage
it's not really part of his body he
grows a handlebar mustache and becomes a
boxer and then a dolphin and then he's
got the hindquarters of a horse to make
himself a centaur and then a beautiful
dress honestly i just think this short
was used to sell variant toys of groot
because i know there are figurines of
all these which i can't really judge
because at the end of the day the full
mcu is really just to sell toys now gerk
gets mocked by this squirrel bird and he
shaves it to turn its plumage into a
scarf now this thing is called a
ganglorian squirrel bird creature
confirmed in the closing credits where
it says none of them were harmed during
the making of this short and then on to
the last episode magnum opus now groot
is aboard the quadrant which is the
smaller detachable pilotable version of
the eclector the one that yondu flies
out of the rest of the collector that
blows up now this doesn't necessarily
mean that this is after they blew up the
rest of the collector in guardians
volume 2 but it does suggest that the
guardians might have crossed paths with
the ravagers in some other instance
maybe took their quadrant ship and
returned it we start by pushing in on
this jansport backpack with patches of
nasa the pacman ghost etc this is peter
quill's backpack this is the one that he
had with him on the night he was
abducted in the 2014 film and the one
that he's always kept with him inside
groot finds an elf comic which is an
actual marvel comics issue alph number
four from 1988 and i love that they got
a timeline specific one there because
that would be a very recent issue of
marvel comics that peter quill had with
him but also poses the question of how
many marvel comics are within the world
of the mcu we know captain america once
were back in the 1940s but since alpha's
such a weird one to be part of the
marvel universe i love that this is the
one they use this is the one where al
flies out of the house where the
family's tablecloth and he says the
princess deferred to the rescue and yes
just to be clear alf was part of marvel
comics this [ __ ] showed up in
reports of thanos victims in infinity
gauntlet and i love this the back cover
of this comic has an ad for pingadoche
this is the brazilian juice that was
bottled in the plant where bruce banner
worked in the 2008 incredible hulk film
where a drop of his blood contaminated a
bottle of this stuff that stan lee would
later drink now groot tears off the
cover of this comic book and throughout
the episode you can barely see the back
of it but it contains the exact print
ads that would exist on the inner fold
of one of these comics groot snips some
fur from rocket's tail get some soap
from drax in the shower but we barely
see him because of the guy so good being
invisible but then also he uses the boot
of peter quill he uses the rocket
propulsors on the side to weld it all
together now tumbling out of his armpit
was actually a glowing yellow battery
this is one of the annulax batteries
that rocket steals from the sovereign
and guardians volume 2 groot tries to
make glitter by blowing up a processing
chip the bomb he makes says cree on it
translating to armed rocket runs over
voice is always by bradley cooper and
yes by the way vin diesel did voice all
the vocalizations of baby groot in the
series a rocket says drax is soap he's
been looking everywhere for this he
won't shut up about it
on that bar soap there are a few hairs
stuck to it i assume they're just
rockets hairs i don't want to think
about it too much now the credits of
this episode read no raccoons or tree
creatures were harmed during the making
of this short the same cannot be said
for the handlers of said raccoons and
tree creatures i believe sound out the
handlers is something that james gunn
would always do in the credits of his
guardians the galaxy movies we get this
little post credit stinger showing the
completed magnum opus artwork floating
beside one of those amylox batteries and
it depicts groot wrapping his arms
around rocket peter quill drax and
gamora showing how he was drawing the
moment he saved them all with the we are
groot moment in the 2014 film as they
crashed to zandar meaning some part of
groot may retain his memories which is
just so beautiful like what is this
broken mj necklace [ __ ] and it was
cutting onions in here yes i might be
older than the demographic these shorts
were intended for but whatever i love
them follow me on instagram and twitter
avos follow new rockstars subscribe to
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you